Dragon is a man shrouded in
mystery. It's time to change that.
Let's be real for a second: What is it with
mysterious characters in One Piece that
barely have any screen time? Shanks, the Gorosei,
Blackbeard. There is just nothing more fascinating
for me than talking about these people who are
incredibly influential and powerful in the world
at large, but that we know close to nothing about.
And Monkey D. Dragon is definitely right
in there, with more gossip and rumours
around him than in a middle school yard.
I want to know what this man is all about.
Hi my name is Manu, I generally assume that if
you have a face tattoo you have lost control over
your life, but today I'm willing to look past
that and analyse Dragon's role in the story.
And of course, this wouldn't be fun
if we didn't speculate a little.
So I have two really solid theories about his
past and one that is just so bat-s**t crazy,
that it would be a crime not to share it with you.
--- I'm really trying to ignore the face
tattoo right now. It's-so distracting.
How drunk were you? Is this a post Malone thing?
'So why did you decide to get a tattoo?'
'Oh you know, I decided to take down the draconic,
all-powerful ruling force that dominates
the entire planet, but then I though: if I
really want people to take me seriously, I should
probably change my look to inspire more respect.'
'-'
Anyways. Let's figure out Dragon's role in the
story so far. This man holds two pretty impressive
titles in the story: He is both, the father of our
protagonist, as well the most wanted man alive.
That is some Roger-level infamy. Let
that sink in for a second. Luffy's father
is a bigger threat to the world government
than Kaido, Big Mom, Blackbeard. I mean,
yeah we talk about that all the time, but
seeing Luffy fighting two Yonko's right now,
that really hits home different. Now while I
think it's fair to assume that Dragon is powerful,
I think we all agree, that a big chunk of
this title is for political reasons. Which
in my eyes makes him even more interesting. What
does Dragon have, that even the Yonko's don't?
I wanna get into that in a second. But let's
first talk about the Monkey family as a whole.
Now, are there a lot of weird and influential
families in One Piece---yes, yes there are. But
Luffy's family in particular stands out among
the them. Luffy himself if the rising star of
the pirate world, the next pirate king and most
likely the man prophesied to change the world.
By the way, did you know that in the Italian
dub Luffy is called: Rubber? Bro, they just
completely removed "Monkey D." and changed luffy
into "rubber" so for half the anime he was simply
"strawhat rubber" until they realised they
f***d up, when they name became important.
His grandfather Garp is the great hero of the
marines, who went head to head with the strongest
pirates in the world, while his father dragon is
the founder and leader of the revolutionary army,
tasked with taking down the world nobles. The
pattern of 3, that Oda really really really loves,
is very prominent here. Each of the three
represents the top level of the 3 major
factions in the world, marines, pirates and
revolutionaries. All 3 of them share a strong
sense of justice, freedom and camaraderie and
are brave and tough to a ridiculous level.
All three of them care about the
people around them, and put their
'work' family over their real family.
I'm not sure if work really fits here.
'So what do you do for a living?'
'I'm a pirate.'
'Oh, how's the pay?'
'Depends, How much you got on you right now?'
And interestingly enough, all three have a mark on
the left side of their face. Luffy and Garp have
a scar, while Dragon has ... agh dammit, just
when I sort of forgot about the tattoo haha.
The monkey family most likely is inspired by the
legend of the three wise monkeys. You know them,
because they turned them into f****g emojis.
One covers his eyes and sees no evil,
one covers his ears and hears no evil and
one covers his mouth to speak no evil. The
story is about cultivating a mindset that will
create a world of harmony, peace and goodwill.
Do you see the connection?
What defines all three, Luffy, Garp
and Dragon, is that they are genuinely
good people, who fight for a world in
which everyone can live a happy live,
regardless of who they are. Garp
represents the best side of the Marines.
Luffy has all sorts of races and quirky characters
in his crew, but so does Dragon. In fact, looking
at the people associated with Dragon really
hammers home the fact that he is Luffy's parent.
There is Ivankov, the leader of the Okama,
a group that is prosecuted in this conservative
world. Sabo, a former noble, who has seen the
cruelty of the royals. You have Hack, a fishman,
representing the revolutionary version of Jinbe,
of the fishmen fighting for a better
and equal life among the other races.
With Koala you have a former slave, that was
an important link between fishmen and humans.
Morley, like chopper would probably
be considered a freak of nature.
Bello Betty is as strong and independent a woman
as you'll ever see. And you also have Kuma,
or as he's called in German 'Bartolomäus
Bär', who connects the revolutionaries to
Vegapunk and the government itself. My
point here is, Dragon has Luffy's crew,
but on a global scale. He shares his sons
ideals, only that he chose a much more
active path. So no wonder that he would
approve of the route that Luffy chose.
Now I'm not a parent myself,
but I dare say that's some
questionable parenting right there.
I think it's never a good sign,
that when someone mentions your father your
first reaction is basically: I have a father?
Well, I can somewhat relate to that. Before
recording this video I checked the notes and:
I have a sponsor? You think
my father is proud of me now?
Well, this video is sponsored by Skillshare, the
caring parent of sponsors, who have supported this
channel for a while now. Big thank you to them.
Skillshare is an online learning community that
offers thousands of classes for all skill levels
in tons of creative and practical disciplines.
I'm taking this class on productivity by
the amazing Thomas Frank right now, because
my schedule right now can best be described as
hell. Maybe I should make a Skillshare course?
The first 1000 of you foxes to click
the link in the description will get a
1 month free trial of Skillshare so you
can start exploring your creativity today.
Now even more interesting than his crew I think,
Dragon has popped up in the most peculiar places.
He was present at Roger's execution, who
inspired everyone there in some way or form.
And he came back, for Luffy's execution as
well, to see him off for the beginning of
his adventure. He was at Shimotsuki village at
Zoro's dojo, to restock supplies and he took in
Robin for the time skip, who got sent to him
by Kuma, part of the revolutionaries himself.
So I think it's not so much speculation
as it is fact, that Dragon has an
active interest in the true history. I don't
think Dragon sought out Robin simply because,
the enemy of my enemy is my friend, I
think we all agree they had things of
importance to discuss. And Robin probably
knows quite a bit of Dragon's plan,
as Luffy most likely is supposed to play a role
in it. But on top of that, Dragon wouldn't be the
most dangerous man in the world, if he didn't have
specific knowledge and the power to back it up.
What makes him such a big threat to the
government, is that he's subscribed to my
Channel for next generation anime content,
that the gorosei fear above all else.
Now that's already a pretty big advantage, but
there must be a bit more to it. And just so you
know, from here we are entering speculation
territory. Two popular ideas are that Dragon
used to be a marine or cypher pole agent and
that he ate a devil fruit that allows him to
control the weather, as it always seems
to change in his favour when we see him.
Just like Zoro however, I want to leave
the known path here and introduce some more
unknown ideas. The first of these is that dragon
might not have a super broken devil fruit,
but that the revolutionary army is
actually in the possession of Uranus,
one of the ancient weapons. We do
know, that Roger found an ancient
weapon and that he managed to escape Shiki without
even fighting by a sudden change of the weather.
We know the first ancient weapon is a ship on the
sea. The second is Shirahoshi under the sea, so
it would make sense that the third weapon is
above the sea and it's not too far a stretch
to speculate that it's able to control the
weather or wind. Know, if Dragon was wielding
one of the 3 weapons that the government fears
so much, that would explain why he is the most
wanted man in the world, especially since he
is aiming it straight at the world nobles.
And another thi-.
Okay you know what: I can't look past that.
Let's talk about that tattoo for a moment.
Why does Dragon have it? He didn't have
it at Roger's execution. So why does a
man so driven by purpose that he left his
child to be raised by his grandfather,
who in turn left it to be raised by bandits,
why does such a man get such a tattoo.
It must have some deeper meaning. The first
possibility I think is a connection to Shandora,
where Tatoo's a quite popular and that follow
the same abstract style. I really like this
connection, because Robin tells us that the
Shandorans used to fight against the world
government and were allied with the ancient
kingdom, or, if you watched the greatest one
piece theory of all time on my channel, it might
actually have been part of the ancient kingdom.
There is a connection to the ancient weapons and
to the sun god Nika, even Roger was there, so it's
not super out there that Dragon knows something
about the Shandoran history and that symbol
in particular, that he found so important and
meaningful, he decided to tattoo it on his face.
The other option is actually even
more interesting. This theory comes
from a YouTube friend of mine called Fiji,
shoutout to him, who found that dragon's
tattoo resembles the one on the kimono of
the one and only legendary samurai Ryuma.
In this version of symbol, there is
a Kanji in the middle of the square,
which means what exactly? Dragon. Which is
a peculiar coincidence, don't you think? But
if this were the only connection to Wano,
that would be a bit weak I think. Only that
we saw Dragon arriving at Shimotsuki village,
named after the damiyo family, Ryuma was part
of. As Oda hinted at in an interview, Dragon has
some sort of relationship with the Dojo master
Koushiro, who is a Shimotsuki himself,
which is confirmed in SBS 96. What Fiji
suggests based on this, is that Dragon
might potentially have traveled to Wano,
that similar to SHandora is another place,
connected to the ancient kingdoms and the
poneglyphs, and thus might have been of
interest to him to search for knowledge or
potential allies. This might have happened
18 years ago, when Shimotsuki Ushimaru, who
based on his appearance we now speculate
to be Zoro's father, was killed by Kaido.
So the reason Dragon knew about Shimotsuki
village might be because he traveled there
before 18 years ago, befriended Ushimaru
before the daimyo planned their rebellion
and got captured and then took Zoro from
Wano to his relative in the east blue.
Ushimaru could have told dragon about his ancestor
Ryuma and their ties to the void century. So there
might be some deeper meaning behind this
symbol, that Dragon then tooted on his face
after leaving Wano. Now this idea rests on
a lot of assumptions, but I think it's solid
enough to make sense and I think it would
really nicely fit in the gaps for Zoro,
that I discussed in his video. Plus it would add
to the already close bond between him and Luffy.
However while this theory is very creative,
it makes a lot of sense. And if you
know me, the crazier a theory the
better I can sleep at night. So I want to
end this video on something truly crazy.
Now a really interesting idea is that Dragon
is actually not Garp son, but Rocks'. However
Liam over at the grand line review has already
made a video about that, the sneaky bastard.
So of course I have to top that by
proposing that Dragon is not Garps son, but
tarps daughter. Hah. Told
you this was gonna get wild.
Okay so if you're a real one pice
fan you'll have come across the
idea that Crocodile actually used to
be a woman, that is Luffy's mother,
that then was transferred into a
man by Ivankov. His 'dark' secret.
I don't know why really, but people love
the s**t. Now this theory is similar,
but takes it a step further. Let's
go down this hormonal rabbit hole.
The base idea is that all the devil fruit
users in the revolutionary army have a power
that helps them operate in secrecy, avoid
detection and rally allies to their side.
Not counting Sabo in this for obvious reasons.
Morley can create hidden underground spaces,
like under Marijoe or in impel down, that
can serve as bases and to move troops.
Betty can enhance people's powers and
strengthen their will to fight. Karasu is
basically an entire private communication and
evacuation system. And then there is Ivankov,
who also can boost up people's bodies,
but most importantly change identities.
Many members of the revolutionaries are
wanted as criminals, pirates or slaves
by the government. Ivankokv's
abilities can give them a
clean sheet, by changing their bodies.
Which is where dragon comes into play.
Dragon is a comlplete mystery to pretty
much everyone. He is a man with no past,
except his connection to garp and luffy. But this
is also strange. No-one was aware that Dragon was
Garp's child, the hero of the marines. Garp
is as public a figure in One Piece as it gets,
and yet no-one knows he had a son? It would
make sense for Garp to not boast about it,
after he became a revolutionary, but
complete ignorance is pretty astonishing.
So what this theory suggest is that Garp had a
daughter, that 'died' but actually turned into the
dragon we know today. In fact, Garp never refers
to Dragon as his son. The theory then goes on
to speculate that Luffy's real father is actually
Roger and that Dragon was sent into the future by
Toki, which is where I definitely jump the ship.
But in general I find the idea that Dragon is
actually Luffy's mother, very very entertaining
to say the least. More than the Crocodile one.
To get the full picture on the monkey family
however, I strongly recommend that you watch
my video on Garp here next. There is
a lot to talk about with him as well.